we make way for the great Reggie Miller
Hall of Famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
Pam crazy crazy times here reg how are
you I'm doing great
unprecedented times these are obviously
in our lifetime we've never seen
anything like this you know sports used
to be the great escape of everyday life
going to the movies you know shows in
Broadway and you know all taken away so
I hope this puts things in perspective
of the important things in life and you
know now to me family time takes even
more importance because you know you're
being asked to you know hunker down and
stay at home so you know we get caught
up on you know I got to be at my next
gig and you know I got to get you know
to work and I got to do this I got you
know time to slow down and appreciate
the things that have always been in
front of you and that's you know family
time and your loved ones and friends and
I think we're kind of getting back to
that a little bit Theodore what happens
though let's say in eight weeks or
whenever it is when the NBA comes back
is the regular season over I don't think
it's over because I believe they will
play anywhere between five to ten games
for players to get rhythm but there's to
me there's many more questions even
before that like what's gonna happen
with the draft right that gets pushed
back let's say we start mid June to late
June and you have five to ten games and
then you go straight into the playoffs
we're looking at the end of July the
beginning of August for around the NBA
Finals so then you have the draft right
after that do you have a modified
version of summer league play and free
agency what about the start of next
season what are the dates on that does
that start end of October and November
like it normally does or does that
pushed to December bigger question
Theodore what happens of the sixteen
teams let's say we do play and a player
test positive of kovat nineteen let's
say you know end of June going into the
playoffs yeah we start this process all
over again
you me me well I think they're trying to
separate as much as they can so you know
that that they don't have that come up
you know that's where you you know
people are like well we should be back
to normal in two weeks I go no no no
maybe two months maybe two months and
even it might be later than that when
and I told the Dennett's I have a friend
who's in the CIA and he said just in the
tri-state area there they think that
we'll be back to normal maybe in June
and that that's coming from somebody in
the CIA
you know anybody's guess right now but
where we are with sports with this you
know delaying baseball the NBA NHL all
the golf stuff the draft stuff I mean
there's a lot of things that are in flux
right now I will certainly say this
because let's say we do start mid-june
to late June we are certainly not going
to put fans at risk I really do believe
that so I think if they do come back and
play games they will be an empty arenas
which to me will be difficult I mean I
think it'll be fine for the players but
I'm sure the fans it's gonna hurt the
fans because obviously they want to see
the games but you can't put fans in arms
way obviously you don't want anyone who
is still dealing with these type of
issues wherever they are to be affected
by this but there's some benefits to
some teams for instance Portland they
could get Youssef Newark itch that
Collin's back to starters right now
there's three and a half back of Memphis
now you get two starters back you know
again you're only playing five to ten
regular-season games is that enough time
to catch Memphis for that a spot what
about the Philadelphia 70
sixers last time we checked Ben Simmons
in bead or hurt now they both come back
and they're pretty much healed they were
on a downslope but now you get your two
best players back and probably healthy
and a long shot here Brooklyn just
Durant
come back there's a possibility right
yes yes there's a possibility he would
come back and play for the playoffs if
you're giving him till mid-june to into
June to come back and play that's
another what month and a half two months
I I could see him possibly coming back
and right now the playoffs were to begin
they would face Toronto in the first
round what did you make a Spencer
Dinwiddie speaking of the Nets he
proposed a 2018 tournament to replace
you know like NCAA style to replace the
rest of the season when you come now I
don't like 28 teams but if you let's say
we did 16 teams and you did round-robin
you know have four number one seat you
know whatever what however you want to
do it but you you you could create
something that was unique this just for
this year alone for the college game no
for the NBA look we need to take a step
back and there's real issues going on I
know people aren't having sports
withdrawal and I get it and I understand
it because I'm one of them but these are
real issues and until we understand what
we are really dealing with in the
transmission and how easy it can be
transmitted I think we need to pause on
what could go down what should go down
we need to take a step back and breathe
a little bit first before we start you
know let's do this let's do that there's
people there's real everyday people that
are being affected by this and I think
we just need to pause well you think
it's insensitive to to try to figure out
what the NBA is going to be like in June
I'm really questioning if that's really
going to happen because the one scenario
I'll keep thinking about is what if
someone you know slowly but surely every
Christian would just tested positive
right the big man from Detroit what is
in a month in May 15th another player
test positive so that slows it down
again doesn't it yeah yeah and what if
someone you know when we start back up
in mid-june late June test positive do
you think we have an NBA champion this
year I really hope we do but I think you
think no I think no because I just don't
see how you know worse if worst-case
scenario happens if players continue to
test positive you're you're you're
continuing to delay this and I hope we
get you know obviously testing but we
get better knowledge of what we're
dealing with I hope we play again I'm
having withdrawals like the rest of you
guys but did you battle track in your
mind reg of did you come in contact with
Rudy Gobert I didn't I had won Utah game
but it was like in I believe in December
okay and I'm curious that everybody in
their minds you know whoever came in
contact with Utah and Donovan Mitchell
and Rudy Gobert probably going wait a
minute but again how about this if he
never would have got tested I think they
would have continued to play game yes I
do too
then he's the inadvertent hero he saved
a lot of people officials fans I mean
this was a trickle-down effect thank God
he got tested I know he's getting a lot
of blowback for the whole you know
touching the mics and joking around
thing but he saved a lot of people he
really did that's why I call him the in
hero because he didn't know what he was
doing at the time but if he doesn't test
positive I'm curious if Donovan Mitchell
gets tested or Christian would with the
Pistons who was tested positive and we
we continue to play games he would have
continued to had tournament games being
played and I don't know you know
how widespread this would have been even
more widespread than it is right now
because we still don't know we don't
have accurate numbers and Theodore the
players would have continued to somewhat
interact with fans I know you know there
was you know an initiative going out
that you know obviously know your hand
touching and limiting autographs but
basketball players professional college
high school because high school is just
as big as college now as much you know
they follow AAU and be our hoops and all
that basketball fans are so recognizable
you know people come up and they want to
take pictures they want to you know hug
there's that's transmission is this the
end of the high five yes it should be
this would be the end of handshaking and
also free throws after you make or miss
then there's no doubt yeah yes and
people don't understand in especially
the I can only speak for a basketball
because I played it for eighteen years
professionally the close proximity you
are in time outs in I mean you're
discussing intimate play in the ear of
your teammate hey I'm gonna do the back
screen here I'm gonna you're always in
close proximity of your teammates
truthfully I'm surprised more NBA
players have not tested positive because
in the locker rooms in the showers on
the training table on the buses in the
airplanes in film sessions you're on top
of one another all the time so I'm
surprised it hasn't been more NBA
players really hey I just saw this Kevin
Durant my business partner rich Klieman
he was on with Golic and Wingo this
morning and talked about
chance of Durant playing in June or July
quote not very realistic honestly not
very realistic from my standpoint and
not even spoken about so if if it
extends into June or July then probably
not something that Durant would be
involved in I just saw that but we also
didn't think that he was gonna play for
Golden State in the finals as well yeah
but I don't want him coming back this
year right I don't want him coming back
I didn't say he would come back I'm
saying they could benefit from a Kevin
Durant if he decided look say he wanted
to come back and play one game of that
series yeah baby was three three he
wanted to play in Game seven no no no I
don't want him back I don't want him
back there but he's a baller and he's a
competitor I know I know
I just wouldn't be surprised I was
telling you I just wouldn't be surprised
I got something for you Paulie has an
idea that we think we could still have
some basketball we do horse so it's by
remote like you take a shot and then all
of a sudden Damian Lillard tries to
match that shot and then LeBron tries to
match that shot then Westbrook does and
then Luca doesn't so so you could do it
from your backyard we could play horse
by remote what is it okay question on
this okay say I take a thirty five
footer and make it yeah and Damian
Lillard is up next is this in live time
or we facetiming so it's real time
yesterday he's not cut and editing it
until he makes it no it's the honor
system
[Laughter]
Paulie what a stupid idea
I get it but you're asking us to okay
how about this reg how about I get five
guys remotely in real time so you take
your shot and then it'll be Lillard
takes his shot
Paul George takes right okay now I'm in
three okay but if you're asking me to I
can cut and you would think Pauly would
know that because he's not very trusting
that but but if we did it in real time
and we did five guys each day and then
you moved on the winner moves on to the
next day and and maybe we do some kind
of grand prize or something I don't know
but you know just we're just thinking
outside the box here yes we do we do it
would be fun though if I got five guys
on one day and then five guys the next
day and you know all of a sudden you
know we get down to Allen Crabbe taking
shots too and hey we just heard from
Mark Cuban
what did Cubans say poll I posted that
this weekend and Cuban hit like he said
it's not as cool okay there's very
trusting so much all we need Shark Tank
money man that's what we get oh you
think so he would back us short you I
like it
okay but it's got to be real time don't
[Laughter]
write hey good to talk to you not sure
when we'll talk again but thanks for
joining us today reg I appreciate
everyone be safe Danette steed or hug
your loved ones and it's good to spend
obviously quality family time that's
most important but stay safe please it's
Reggie Miller Hall of Famer